saint denis sa basilique eux ces rues
photographiées par robert doisneau ces
ateliers tgv derrière cette énumération
l'ambition d'une ville devant lieu de
devenir une cité touristique
pas question bien sûr de rivaliser avec
saint tropez ou biarritz saint denis
souhaite simplement tirer profit de la
proximité de la capitale
c'est la première ville de proche
banlieue à jouer à fond la carte
touristique où passez-vous vos
prochaines vacances
loin très loin et pourquoi pas à saint
denis tout près de chez vous non ce
n'est pas une blague
la mairie de saint denis a inventé le
tourisme de banlieue avec 10 millions
d'habitants en ile-de-france et 20
millions de visiteurs par an à paris la
vague de touristes et potentiellement
déferlante
pour l'heure la ville des quartiers nord
n'accueille que 150 mille curieux par an
par l'ambition de rivaliser avec notre
dame avec la tour eiffel mais on a
l'ambition de rattraper
le coeur qui existent si l'on pouvait
atteindre 50% des moteurs qui vont
chaque année à la tour eiffel et notre
dame soyons très satisfait on aurait
multiplié par cinq en quoi notre nombre
de touristes par an
saint denis sa basilique
sa nécropole des rois sont nous et
l'histoire
ces vieux quartier immortalisé par
doisneau
non
son marché cosmopolite l'exotisme au
coin de la rue pour un tourisme de
proximité
saint denis veut prouver qu'elle a un
patrimoine historique et contemporain ce
que la mettre en valeur et montrer que
tout n'est pas négatif justement puis ça
permet aux gens d'éviter d'aller sur
paris pour voir des choses intéressantes
500 chambres d'hôtels aujourd'hui le
double dans trois ans saint denis by
night voudrait ne plus être saint denis
cité dortoir